only two candidates remain on Sunday  night the final of the eviction reaches  the ultimate climax one final task  stands in the way of Hannah and Anthony  as they dream of taking home Sam you  lose twenty thousand pounds cash prize  eleven candidates are fallen by the  wayside but Canon C finalists hold their  nerve as the race to be crowned champion  unravels in this thrilling series finale  there have been 20,000 pound transferred  into let us know in the comments below  who you think will win the competition  and who's Samuel will transfer 20,000  pounds to live in front of their eyes  Sunday 7 p.m. is the grand final of the  eviction